madame darrieux une première question un
peu sous forme de détail vont parler
vraiment de votre film il paraît que
vous portez dans ce film les mêmes
boucles d'oreilles que dans madame 2
c'est vrai c'est oui que je craque fois
la fraîcheur des petites pompes
l'oreille avec des choeurs effectivement
pour un hommage à max ophuls lola ne
sont pas du même nom et beaucoup
d'affaires de qu ailleurs dans ce film
parce que si vous enlevez le télévie
écrit ce film pour en mémoire de sa mère
il là il a aussi voulu que ce soit vous
qui l'interprètent y est oui il fait
beaucoup
oui mais je pense parce que quand ils
étaient petits ressorts et même pour la
première fois au cinéma et alors
il est identique peut-être à sa mère je
ne sais pas je crois que c'était aussi
un de vos admirateurs très profond que
j'avais quelque chose que les 4000
photos de farrell
alors l'histoire elle même est une
affaire de sentiments c'est une histoire
d'amour
ben oui certains moments c'est une femme
qui bien sûr d'amour mais moi je sais
très mal parler des personnages vous la
trouvez cette femme
cette femme que vous interprétez un peu
ce personnage mais je ne sais pas
comment je la trouve je ne cherche pas
du tout expliqué les personnages que je
joue j'essaie de les jouer
c'est un huissier à dire parce que je
crois que de parler les personnages
c'est l'auteur qui peut en parler par
contre l'interprète essaie de faire
passer ce qu'a voulu écrire l'auteur qui
ne peut pas être tout seul puisqu'il
faut une interprète pour jouer le rôle
je pense que c'était un rôle merveilleux
parce que c'est une femme pleine de
sensibilité d'amour de tendresse de bon
vous avez lu le synopsis et le script
tout de suite vous avez dit oui c'est
tout de suite ça vous à ça vous a attiré
1 oui ça m'a accroché tout de suite j'ai
trouvé ça très beau j'ai pas tout
compris par à cause du découpage n'a pas
l'histoire mais je veux dire le film est
assez spécial en ce qui concerne le
montage qui est fait avec le présent
bien sûr et le plus important puisque ce
qui se passe à toulon mais avec les
fantasmes ici de françoise et puis à peu
de flashbacks naturellement lui dit que
c'est un personnage
bon peut-être pas dur mais difficile oui
parce que d'abord vous menez tout le
long du film vous êtes présidente
absolument tout le long du film kick
finalement assez rare dans un film
oui ils voient ça au théâtre voir -
rarement vous aiderai on voit plus
rarement cmao c'est un rôle difficile
c'est vrai que c'est un rôle très
difficile et de ce fait je dirais
presque que c'est plus facile de jouer
un rôle difficile que de jouer un rôle
trop facile je passais une compresse
bijoux dire parce que avant le difficile
et sensible
c'est un bonheur de tous les instants
d'essayer de l'interprète paix jusqu'à
rôle facile
c'est pas c'est pas tellement
passionnant alors on n'y est même pas
grand chose je crois
est ce que j'avais la même même façon de
choisir de choisir vos scripts est-ce
que vous réagissez de la même manière je
parlais de théâtre quand vous choisissez
un script de terre d'où une pièce le
cinéma pièces non ce qu'est ce qui est
terrible dans le théâtre c'est qu'on ne
sait absolument pas où on va au cinéma
non plus me dirai aux classes comme on
est là présent avec on on répète pendant
un mois en se disant c'est une aventure
qui va durer et on ne sait jamais c'est
très difficile de juger une pièce parce
que le public de théâtre on sait pas
tellement bien ce qui va email en tous
les cas là le film il est fait là le
film est fait et de juger voilà en haut
des marches donc de paul décalé avec
danielle darrieux merci madame merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur notre plateau